il ya eu beaucoup de lancement la
semaine dernière beaucoup d'actualité
dans ses actualités via un smartphone
qui est sortie dont je voulais
absolument vous parler c'est celui là
c'est le au nord 9 fixe la gamme d
honneur femme est de rendre accessible
au grand public les technologies des
flagships c'est en tout cas ce que nous
dit au nord et c'est ce qu'ils veulent
faire en tout cas une fois de plus avec
ceux aux normes fixe quelles promesses
ils nous font avec ceux au nord de fixe
les promesses vous les avez là écran
fulvio immersif sans aucune encoches
avec la caméra pop-up triple caméra avec
nous des photos 48 mégapixels on a
ensuite la mémoire 128 g guin ultra
rapide en ef s 2.1 et la troisième c'est
le port usb c'est on va donc regarder si
les promesses faites par au nord sur le
aux normes fixes sont intéressantes
est ce qu'elles sont tenues qu'est ce
qu'elle vous apporte au final est-ce
qu'il faut acheter ce smartphone oui ou
non
[Musique]
et n'oubliez pas avant tout le mois de
novembre c'est vous qui votez pour élire
le smartphone de l'année dans chaque
catégorie j'en ai déjà parlé il va y
avoir un grand soir et de la téléphonie
mobile
début décembre avec les acteurs de la
téléphonie mobile avec l'écosystème de
la téléphonie mobile
et c'est vous qui votez c'est vous qui
allez dire quels sont les smartphones
quel smartphone mérite de gagner
vous votez je vous remets julien une
fois de plus en bas et je veux mais
également le lien de la vidéo comme ça
vous saurez tout alors avant de
commencer justement ce test du riz en
fixe je vous emmène avec moi à paris
dans une brasserie parisienne au moment
où j'ai récupéré le horn fixe
directement auprès de l'équipe diodore
histoire de refaire un petit récap sur
la gamme x 2 au nord et après on rentre
dans le vif du sujet on se respecte pas
ce que je bois un petit coup avec goût
de la tille de honor pour parler du
nouveau smartphone qui est juste là la
planque et on vous a mis la boîte ici
netflix et là on a plein de smartphones
c'est tous les modèles x en fait ça en
commençant 5 x 5 6
tu vois l'évolution déjà au niveau des
développeurs 5 x 6 6 7 7 6 8 6 et le 9 x
qui vient d'arriver on voit il ya plus
d'encoches entre deux heures c'est vrai
que ça distingue c'est vachement bien
c'est grand écran comme ça un trait
dégage vachement c'est vraiment chouette
c'est drôle on peut vraiment l'évolution
avec tu avais un point b qui était
énorme quand malicieux entre le haut et
le bas tant pas trop à s'affiner mais ça
change de couleur un peu plus grand
écran ici la langue corse a dégagé quand
même c'était un mec cool ils m'ont fait
les a les alliés les pluies de logo et
la sage ou alors du coup la blogo vous
l'avez mis à l'arrière il planquette
j'ai montré ces dernières et rage de
voir sa saison
c'est drôle ça la thaïlande ou le cam
capteurs ici capteurs la double km un
peu caché différemment double k mais la
triple gamme à partir de cette année et
on regarde le capteur d'empreinte
digitale au dos et là on voyage dans le
temps quand même pas mal ton petit c'est
la carotte la femme analphabète après un
cocasse est beaucoup plus raisonnable
moi je suis au courant et qui combine
bien regardez moi ça comme c'est mignon
cette jolie petite boîte très sympa bond
à des codes un peu classique de honor ça
marche bien
y'a rien de bien d'un goût dans la boîte
mais en tout cas l'idéal est plutôt
sympa et surtout le clou du spectacle se
situe ici sur le honor ne fit alors ses
passions le voit bien c'est très
compliqué à voir on a des reflets sur le
modèle bleu alors que sur le modèle bleu
vous fait un x et vous voyez un peu là
comme ça alors c'est vraiment une
signature de honor et je trouve ça
vraiment très sympa alors on a un dos
avec un méfait vert mais c'est pas du
tout du verre on est sur un dos
plastique
je vous conseille quand même devenir
protéger parce que même si les tribus
comme ça on sait que les smartphones
n'aime pas trop les changements plus
qu'on a absolument aucune protection
derrière on est sur un dock plastique
donc pensé quand même à le protéger
et comme vous le voyez à l'arrière d'un
triple module caméra xi positionné à une
caméra bon ça marche un design est très
sympa il trouvait le branding au nord
ici toutes les petites normes
européennes qui sont bien cachés qu'on
voit pas trop mais qui sont quand même
présente on a ici le lecteur
d'empreintes digitales qui marche qui
est très rapide on peut ce sens doit se
déverrouille ça c'est vraiment très très
très cool pour après un grand classique
bouton de volume ton pourrait allumer
pour l'éteindre haut parleurs
usb c'est donc déjà première promesse de
tenues micro prise jack
ça c'est vraiment cool petite caméra pop
up sur le dessus on faisait pouvoir
retrouver votre tiroir de capter pour m
soit deux anneaux sim soit une année
6000 carte micro sd est ici le micro
pour la réduction de bruit et sur la
face avant on retrouve le grand écran et
c'est ça qui pour moi en tout cas est
vraiment intéressant sur ce smartphone
c'est la première promesse qui est fait
sur ce smartphone c'est le fait d'avoir
ce grand écran cent en poche il pour le
coup la promesse est tenue l'écran est
plutôt bien globalement mais surtout ce
qui est vraiment intéressant est ce qui
fait vraiment que la force de ce
smartphone c'est que tu un peu plus
immersif c'est à dire que lorsque vous
allez regarder du contenu comme ça et
bien vous n'avez pas dans coach vous
êtes vraiment libéré des contraintes
techniques de l'encoche la caméra et
planck héros et c'est pour moi en tout
cas le gros point fort de ce smartphone
alors il ya la photo on en parle dans
quelques instants mais vraiment le gros
focus qui est fait sur ce smartphone si
vous voulez un smartphone sens
absolument aucune encoches à 249 euros
le honneur de fix est vraiment cool on a
un écran de 6,59 tous ses duels c'est
d'ailleurs c'est pas le sim dali ps
c'est une dalle led tps mais il se
trouve que elle fonctionne plutôt pas
mal en résolution 2340 par 1080 pixels à
391 pixels par pouce
ça va pas être le plus bel écran qu'on
peut retrouver sur le marché on est sur
un smartphone à 249 euros donc il faut
vraiment raison gardée par rapport à ça
mais il fonctionne bien moi ce que je
vous conseille quand même c'est de venir
dans les réglages dans affichage et
ensuite d'en mode des températures de
couleur vous allez l'avoir en mode
normal en couleurs vives mettez-vous en
normal ça va légèrement venir un petit
peu cassé parce que si vous le mettez en
couleurs vives
il ya beaucoup de bleu qui ressort
jonças carmen beaucoup moins jolie de
kourouma ça va venir les réchauffe un
petit peu c'est beaucoup plus agréable
et après si vous la leyre je plussoie
vous le mettez en couleurs chaudes vous
venez légèrement règle est là et là pour
moi vous allez le meilleur combo dans ce
smartphone
alors après vous avez la partie confort
des yeux qui je trouve vraiment est pas
belle du tout c'est d'y attirer sur
l'espèce de deux jeunes un peu vert et
même en menant le casser c'est pas beau
lapointe coup ça c'est pas terrible
terrible
à côté de ça vous avez un écran qui est
certifié pour filtrer la lumière bleue
dont ça s'est vraiment bien et très
important et qui occupe surtout 91% de
la face avant donc l'usagé numéro qu'on
va voir sur ce produit c'est l'aspect
multimédia pour utiliser sur tous vos
réseaux sociaux pour aller naviguer sur
internet pour regarder des vidéos
c'est vraiment hypra agréable
maintenant le petit bémol lorsque vous
allez regarder des vidéos c'est l'audio
je trouve que le petit haut parleur que
vous avez ici n'est pas extraordinaire
il restitue un son qui rapidement saturé
on est sur le médium cépage est pas
content pour qu'ils très positif et qui
pour moi en tout cas
élève l'expérience multimédia c'est la
prise jack vous avez ici une petite
prise jack et c'est là que ça devient
vraiment très très intéressant parce que
la qualité quand même beaucoup plus et
alors on va manquer légèrement de grave
ne peut pas tout avoir mais si vous avez
un casque est de bonne qualité et bien
faits pour profiter d'une expérience
multimédia qui va être augmentée
intéressante skis en tout cas fait pour
moi de ce smartphone à 249 euros une
très belle proposition pour le
multimédia
je vous dis une fois de plus réseaux
sociaux vidéos je je je
oui je aussi avec notamment un petit
aspect de l'oeuvre partout on est dessus
et fonctionner alors vous n'allez pas
pouvoir faire tourner mais quand même
pas mal de petites du pesto asseoir
dessus vous avez hop là vous avez un
kirin 710 f 4 gigas de ram
lp ddr4 x 128 giga de stockage
en effet ce 2.1 c'est en tout cas un
truc et à saintes avant c'est une
promesse qui est fait par au nord là
dessus le fait de pouvoir effectivement
retrouvé de l'ue fs 2.1
c'est plutôt cool on peut déraper on
peut jouer on peut faire pas mal de
choses avec ce jeu ça fonctionne
donc quand côté purement divertissement
uni avec ce smartphone maintenant il ya
un autre - qui est aussi intéressant
c'est l'autonomie vous avez une grosse
batterie de 4000 milliampères heures
c'est plutôt bien si vous parlez tenir
jusqu'à deux jours ça dépend une fois de
plus de vos usages peut toujours reste
un peu prudents avec l'autonomie parce
que si vous y allez énormément vous le
savez également le patriote durant un
peu moins longtemps si par contre vous
êtes un peu plus cool vous et pouvoir
aller jusqu'à deux jours ça c'est bien
pas compte qu'un truc c'est que
effectivement vous avez beau avoir de la
recharge ici en usb c'est ça c'est une
première défaite dont elle est tenue
vous n'avez pas de recharge rapide vous
avez en charge lundi soit inclus dans la
boîte ce qui fait que si vous vous levez
le matin vous l'état mince j'ai oublié
de chargement smartphones nla falloir
s'armer de patience soit menée une peur
monte avec vous pour le recharger
tranquillement dans les transports en
commun dans votre voiture ou ce que vous
voulez savoir prendre votre mal en
patience parce que c'est pas de la
recharge extrêmement rapide
une fois de plus sur les smartphones à
249 euros donc on peut pas tout avoir
mais je dirais qu'en tout cas le point
le plus intéressant sa carrière cette
grosse batterie de 4 millions perdra
tout paraît décalé relativement
tranquille concernant la partie os on
est sur eux m 8 9 points 1.0 qu'il
tourne sur un android 9 payal ans
rassurez-vous la très très bonne
nouvelle la danse est effectivement
c'est un smartphone qui a la licence
android donc vous êtes absolument
croquer vous pouvez l'acheter sans aucun
problème vous et pourra retourner tout
votre place tahrir à vos applications su
après à côté de ça moi la mue je suis
pas hyper hyper hyper fan c'est parce
que je vais préférer mais à côté de ça
ça gâche pas la fête libre il ya un coin
qui est intéressant sur smartphones
maintenant c'est la partie photo alors
il ya des choses qui sont très
intéressante qui vont bien aidé a
d'autres qui sont un peu moins terrible
jeu déjà vous dire ce qu'on a en termes
de spécifications techniques sur la
partie photo vous montrer la partie
logicielle bientôt qui est pas mal
et puis vous montrer les résultats
qu'ils escomptent en vue pour le dire en
bas on commenté à ce que vous en pensez
si on se regarde purement et simplement
la fiche technique comme vous le voyez
vous avez trois caméras derrière je
pense que là je ne vous apprends
absolument rien c'est clair c'est
limpide ça se voit c'est là vous allez
voir une première caméra de 48
mégapixels c'est une somme i mx 5 182 kg
ouvre à f 1.8 qui vous permet en gros
dans la technologie ka pixels en un ce
qui fait que lorsque des temps photo
nuit et bien de pouvoir capter plus de
lumière en gros tout ce qu'il faut
savoir
vous avez une deuxième caméra deuxième
caméra 8 mégapixels sont ultra
grand-angle de 120° qui ouvre à f 2.4
jusque là tout va bien tout est normal
et une troisième caméra 2 mégapixels qui
est là pour la profondeur de champ pour
les facebook était à l'avant vous avez
une petite caméra qui est planqué juste
là regardez là la regardez moi ça comme
c'est mignon c'est une petite caméra de
5 mégapixels et ouvre à f 2.2 et kiki
rétractable qui se cache
lorsque vous allez jeter le smartphone
comme ça et bien voyez elle rentre tout
seul pour des questions de sécurité au
niveau de la partie logicielle en
elle-même vous voyez les photos un petit
peu classique
vous allez avoir la partie lâche la
partie pour l' ultra grand-angle voyez
alors regardez bien je sais pas si vous
le voyez là mais lorsque je me rapproche
c'est des formes envoyé au niveau du
poste le poste est extrêmement des
formes intention de faire une faute au
tac
et lorsque vous regardez le résultat je
n'ai plus les faits complètement
déformée là il ya une vraie correction
alors la correction elle se fait en post
prod a se fait une fois que la photo a
été prise
tout simplement pour des questions de
puissance à mon avis au niveau du
smartphone ça ne vous connaissent pas en
temps réel lorsque vous regardez comme
ça et bien vous allez voir ce que vous
voyez à travers la lentille tout
simplement mais une fois de plus lorsque
vous allez venir shooter votre photo
ça ça disparaît complètement ça vous
calcule en gros ça vous le corrigé
depuis correction qui est quand même pas
mal c'est pas complètement parfait mais
ça fonctionne ça c'est bien de ça c'est
vraiment intéressant parce que ça évite
ce côté trop déformé de l' ultra
grand-angle
alors on va avoir effectivement eu
différentes bulles
différences de couleurs notamment au
niveau du rendu du très grand temps de
vous coller sur les objectifs
différences séparent extrêmement grave
on va pouvoir venir ensuite zoomer pour
pouvoir monter jusqu'à un zoom x 6
numérique
bon c'est pas ouf mais ça fonctionne je
vous montrais le résultat dans quelques
instants vous êtes bien évidemment aussi
et toujours de l'intelligence
artificielle va pouvoir faire aussi vos
photos en mode portrait le fameux cliché
nocturne je montais en quelques instants
le mot d'ouverture
je sais pas qui utilise le mot
d'ouverture des heures dites moi si vous
vous l'utilisez vous si vous l'avez
utiliser un jour la bolivie la vidéo la
vidéo qui est stabilisé jusqu'en 720p
lâché en 1080p je le tiens voyez pas du
tout ça de l'elysée lorsque je me
positionne ensuite un plat je viens là
en 720p à 30 images par seconde
et bien ce moment là vous voyez il ya
une stabilisation logiciel c'est quand
même beaucoup mieux bon à côté de ça
vous allez perdre quasiment résolution
mais si vous voulez vraiment quelque
chose de stabiliser pour y aller mais
une fois de plus ça sera des vidéos qui
sont pas complètement folle et
complètement dingue vous pouvez ensuite
avoir un mode hdr mode pro si vous
souhaitez panoramique time lapse failli
être pas mal de petites options fluide
filigrane combat plus intéressant ce
qu'ont utilisé depuis six avec photo
portrait pourquoi pas mais surtout le
mode clichés nocturne on arrive donc là
sur une des promesses majeures qui est
fait par honor regarder sur leur petite
fille si vous le voyez la petite caméra
de 40 8 mégapixels qui mise en premier
même avant l'écran full vie pour moi
l'écran full vous ça reste quand même le
truc le plus intéressant mais pourquoi
pas on va se regarder cette caméra 48
mégapixels si au final elle tient ses
promesses prime nos choix sont prises
avec le capteur principal jean les
petits soucis mais surprise du dessus et
là c'est pas mal parce que on retrouve
quand même il ya pas beaucoup de lumière
quand on suppose et de photos mais on
trouve quand même bien les détails et on
peut venir un petit peu zoomer récemment
voyez on vient quand même de la
précision ce site où l'intéressé le
caméra 48 mégapixels alors le zoom n'est
pas complètement infinie quand on se
rapproche trop envie on va récupérer
quand même pas mal de bruit mais voyez
on parle de ça on se rapproche on aura
quelque chose quand même qui a cédé fini
donc la promesse est vraiment
intéressante est tenue en tout cas au
niveau de ce capteur 48 mégapixels
lorsque je le tout avec l'ultra grand
temps tout de suite c'est beaucoup moins
intéressant de rouler sur une caméra 8
mégapixels donc rien de bien étonnant on
va pas venir ou mais parce qu'on va
récupérer quelque chose de d'un prêt si
beaucoup
bruisser bataille c'est vraiment pour un
effet extérieur j'ai ce qu'on passe en
clichés nocturne tenu à la main avec une
exposition un peu plus longue
la gestion des lumières est pas parfait
son côté c'est pas extraordinaire on
n'est pas sur un smartphone fait pour
faire des photos de nuit le mode existe
vous permet de le faire la caméra tout
cas de 48 me rappeler avec la
technologie 4x au lendemain vous permet
de le faire mais les rendus sont pas les
croyances sont pas là il faut jouer une
nuit blagnac avec pas mal de lumière
petits plats avec des ravioles je sais
ça peut paraître un peu bizarre mais
c'est un petit lac d'aggraver les ponts
c'était quand même trois mois pas mal
il ya des pas énormément lumière prises
avec le capteur 48 mégapixels c'est pas
j'ai 15h48 mégapixels tenu à la main il
n'y a pas de stabilisation donc
forcément avec moi syllabes se bat pas
tout de suite pardonner on arrête le
capteur ultra grand-angle c'est pas très
très très précis caméra principale des
clubs beaucoup de lumière avec le 48
mégapixels ça fonctionne on peut venir
jouer davantage voyons récupère quand
même pas mal de choses ça fonctionne
plutôt bien
on s'assure ultra-grand-angle la
colorimétrie n'est pas la même au niveau
du ciel c'est un peu plus pâle bon c'est
pas anormal non plus fait plus dans
cette gamme de tarifs caméra principale
48 milliards pixels la gestion du
contre-jour est pas mal tu seras
grand-angle caméra principale piste sera
grand angle et la société sts et le zoom
fois ci se voyait on arrive quand même à
sortir quelque chose avec le zoom
numérique faut 6 c'est pas d'un go mais
on peut le faire
c'est assez rigolo 48 mégapixels juste
rag grand temps que peut être
intéressant lorsque vous voulez chanter
des monuments ou des bâtiments et que
vous avez pas le recul nécessaire dans
ces méga pixels ultra grand-angle et le
zoom numérique fois 6,48 mégapixels
c'est rigolo et dès que ça soit ultra
grand-angle c'est moi précis le poids ne
se fait pas c'est pas terrible mais il
avait la petite caméra de pop-ups elfi
qui fonctionne pas mal
alors si on récapitule les promesses qui
sont faites notre communiqué de presse
et bientôt écrans full view immersif
sans aucune encoches avec la caméra pop
up très clairement c'est pour moi le
gros point fort de ce smartphone qui
pendant une très belle proposition de
valeur d'avoir effectivement un
smartphone sans absolument aucune
encoches avec un grand écran dégager
comme ça à 249 euros
la promesse est tenue donc beau boulot
au nord dessus trip caméra avec module
principal 48 mégapixels en effectivement
une triple caméra en effectivement un
module 48 mégapixels mais la pluie peu
caméra va pas forcément être
extraordinaire sur tous les points de
vue le module 40 8 mégapixels avec aso
10 mx 5 182 marche bien elle marchait
lorsque vous avez vous
cool lumière lorsque vous allez ajouter
des photos pour les réseaux sociaux que
les pouvoirs mis un petit peu recadré en
zone en dedans je dirais que c'est
l'usagé plus intéressant l'ultra grand
angle vraiment de temps en temps lorsque
vous êtes en extérieur que vous avez un
bâtiment que vous ne pouvez pas shooter
autrement mais voit pas avoir la
meilleure qualité là dessus en photo
nuit on peut sortir des choses mais
c'est pas là pour avoir les meilleurs
rendu une fois de plus on est sûrement
un smartphone à 249 euros on peut pas
avoir le même rendu qu'un smartphone qui
va coûter 600 ou 800 euros
donc une fois de plus on repositionne
par rapport à sa gamme de tarifs
il fait le job il le fait plutôt bien
avec la caméra de 48 mégapixels mémoire
128 giga ultra rapide du ffs deux points
c'est vrai qu'il ya un gars qu'une
évolution par rapport à la version
précédente où vous n'avez pas de le ffs
deux points ont donc ça c'est bien
et le porn sbc alors le port usb c'est
là par contre on pourrait regretter en
tout cas de ne pas voir de recharge plus
rapide on se dirait effectivement on a
un port usb c'est on aurait un port
microusb ne changerait pas grand chose
dans la mesure où effectivement vous
n'avez que charger d'iwate inclus mais
bon il est là donc on peut pas dire que
la promesse n'est pas tenue
alors qu'est ce que j'en pense mathieu
smartphones et c'est là où mon espèce de
ty burrell ce smartphone est fait pour
vous si vous utilisez le côté multimédia
si vous êtes un consommateur de série un
consommateur de films de réseaux sociaux
et que vous ne voulez pas dans coche sur
le dessus et que vous voulez profiter
d'un grand écran bien dégagé celle
utilisée avec un casque ici en jack ou
alors en bluetooth à savoir vous avez
des blue tooth 4.2 ici pas de bluetooth
5.0 puisque si vous allez l'écouter
directement comme ça c'est pas officines
donc pour usage multimédia ça fonctionne
mais je vole vite fait plus au casque
attention mettez pas son trop fort
protégez vos oreilles pour la photo
louis photos plutôt du jour avec le
capteur de 48 mégapixels et ce sont
vraiment les deux gros point positif est
intéressant de ce smartphone donc à 249
euros pourquoi pas il ya des choses
aussi qui sont intéressantes à la
concurrence
à ce tarif là même avec un grand écran
comme ça mais en tout cas celui là il
fait le job je trouve intéressant est ce
que j'aime beaucoup en tout cas le petit
design qui est déjà fait derrière avec
les faits je sais pas sur trois mais bon
j'ai pas forcément l'éclairage très très
évident ici c'est bien ce d'or cet effet
il est il est vraiment sympa
il est plus sain par garder à l'oeil
c'est très difficile à filmer ce genre
de choses mais j'aime bien alors ça ne
marche que sur le modèle bleu sur le
modèle noir vous ne l'avez pas mais en
tout cas ce smartphone moi je trouve
bien intéressant donc si vous intéresse
vous pouvez y aller s'il répond bien
évidemment aux usages dont je vous ai
parlé dans la vidéo s'il vous battre
vous a mis un lien en bas d'un
description et sur ce je vous donne
rendez vous dès demain et vous verrez
bien gros bisous des immenses bec et
puis surtout portez vous bien hein et
puis n'hésitez pas à poser toutes vos
questions suggestions directement bas en
commentaire à demain ciao